[Música]
es que la guerra nuclear ya ha impactado
en todos los terrenos como estábamos
conversando con más romeros a la incluso
el religioso la postura del papá
francisco y el patriarca de la iglesia
ortodoxa rusa kiril sobre el conflicto
nos ha llevado a subir el tono de sus
comentarios en una videollamada con
kiril el jerarca católico lo llamó
monaguillo de putin por su apoyo a la
invasión a ucrania de las posturas
belicistas del presidente ruso por su
parte el líder ortodoxo calificó a
francisco como el capellán de occidente
por sus continuas denuncias sobre los
ataques en la población civil y
ucraniana la relación entre la iglesia
ortodoxa rusa y el vaticano siempre ha
sido tensa y este conflicto bélico pone
en evidencia una vez más todas sus
diferencias para ello entonces quiero
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado del
día él es marcial sánchez gaete analista
doctor en historia y experto en historia
de la iglesia católica marcial gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 la situación actual
de las iglesias en todo este conflicto
cuales en su opinión
está ocurriendo realmente entre la
iglesia católica y la iglesia ortodoxa
rusa
hola muy buen día mira la verdad lo que
pasa es que el papá ha dicho lo que
siente y este papá francisco lo ha hecho
siempre así como francisco siempre desde
que
asumió el pontificado ha planteado los
puntos de vista según a él le parecen
después de una reunión con el patriarca
ruso en donde él mismo cuenta que 40
minutos el patriarca ruso estuvo dando
cuenta lo que significa la guerra ante
ucrania desde rusia pero justificando la
al final pudieron conversar lo que pasa
es que estas 12 iglesias días del año
mil 453 cuando ya se produce la división
y desde allí en adelante no han podido
llegar a acuerdos hay que recordar que
un acercamiento que hubo con campa de lo
segundo en su momento no llega a su fin
adecuado no son muchas las diferencias
las que tienen estas dos iglesias más
bien son diferencias de rito pero no
necesariamente en cuanto a lo que
significa el fondo del cristianismo el
papá
francisco le ha dado a entender de que
el cristianismo es una religión que
nació desde la paz para la paz en el
mundo y que no puede efectivamente el
patriarca ruso dar cuenta de la
justificación del hecho de la guerra ese
es el punto del fondo ahora la forma de
plantear las cosas uno puede
encontrarlas a lo mejor muy desmentidas
o muy ventiladas pero en términos reales
yo creo que el papá francisco estaba muy
molesto y estaba muy molesto porque
esperaba que efectivamente un patriarca
ruso una iglesia ortodoxa rusa que tiene
miembros creyentes en ucrania y también
miembros en rusia podían efectivamente
hacer un nexo virtuoso para poder
encontrar la paz lo que efectivamente no
se está dando hay que recordar que en el
año 2010 putin tiene un acercamiento
directo con la iglesia ortodoxa rusa
además asumiendo que él se siente
cristiano ortodoxo pero lo que hace en
el año 2010 es entregarle a la iglesia
todos a rus los bienes los bienes que
fueron arrebatados después de la
revolución del año 17 de 1917 por lo
tanto hay una cercanía directa entre el
gobierno de putin y la iglesia ortodoxa
y ese acercamiento cada día se hace más
y más homogéneo es decir cada día ese
acercamiento está marcando una pauta lo
cual el papá francisco considera
lamentable y da cuenta a los dichos que
tú estás dando a conocer en esta nota
marciales vamos a hablar un poco de
historia no históricamente como han sido
todas estas todas estas relaciones entre
esas iglesias la ortodoxa rusa y la
católica y a lo mejor mencionar el punto
más álgido de las tensiones entre las
iglesias
mira lo que pasa es que hay que
remontarse hay que remontarse al siglo
primero de acuerdo el siglo primero el
apóstol andrés es el que llega a la zona
de kiev eso es importante que la gente
sepa era la zona de quien posteriormente
aparece el mundo hoy día conocemos lo
que conocemos hoy día como rusia de
acuerdo o reducida eran muchos pantanos
pero en la parte de kiev de acuerdo ahí
nace todo y es ahí donde donde llega el
cristianismo con el apóstol con el
apóstol andrés y es ahí en adelante
comienza a expandirse el cristianismo
hasta el año 900 88 en el año 900 88
vladimiro primero de acuerdo de kiev en
contra de matrimonio con la hermana del
emperador vacilo segundo y ahí se hace
esta iglesia esta iglesia cristiana de
acuerdo se hace la iglesia del imperio
del imperio del imperio
de rusia del rush de kiev que se le
llamaba bueno desde ahí en adelante
comienza una historia y esta historia
tiene un quiebre en el año mil 453
cuando se convierte de acuerdo
rusia se convierte como se le habla de
la tercera roma tenias constantinopla
por un lado tenias roma y tenías
y tenías esta zona de quiebre bueno el
tema es que de ahí en adelante han
habido bastantes contratiempos diría yo
sea trataron de llegar a acuerdos y se
trataron de lograr acuerdos pero no se
ha podido lograr acuerdos especiales son
los motivos son varios primeros a nivel
de la jerarquía hay que recordar que los
sacerdotes ortodoxos rusos pueden
casarse por ejemplo el tema del celibato
12 sin excusa muy profunda con respecto
al tema del celibato que discusión que
ya también se ha dado en el mundo
occidental con la iglesia católica que
nosotros conocemos en occidente pero no
se pueden casar acá de acuerdo en el
mundo occidental pero sí en el mundo
ortodoxo luso se pueden casar pero los
obispos no pueden estar casados y
entonces allí hay una discusión y esa
discusión ha llevado a plantear de
acuerdo a la iglesia ortodoxa rusa quien
muchas de las prerrogativas creadas por
el mundo occidental bien entre el punto
la media no necesariamente el
planteamiento bíblico de cristo marcial
ya para finalizar nuestra conversación
que además es muy interesante y yo por
mí podríamos quedarnos horas hablando
pero pues como sabe el tiempo una
televisión muy cortico tenemos
aproximadamente 40 segundos para hablar
de cómo va a quedar entonces estas
relaciones tras el conflicto
bueno vamos a ver que tú me preguntas
tras el conflicto yo no sé cuándo va a
terminar el conflicto un acuerdo en el
momento que termina el conflicto vamos a
ver pero hoy día las relaciones están
muy quebradas y están quebradas porque
efectivamente el papá francisco tiene
una postura muy clara y es no a la
guerra ya también ha tomado una postura
más bien occidental en cuanto a la
atrocidad que estamos viendo de
occidente no es porque la guerra haya
llegado al mundo europeo sino porque es
una guerra atroz como ya lo estábamos
viendo la nota anterior
en otras palabras efectivamente la
guerra ha tocado el mundo civil ha
tocado a todas las esferas y eso
obviamente lo estamos observando de
acuerdo a través de la prensa lo estamos
observando todos los días de la muerte
de las matanzas que se están produciendo
obviamente que es una situación que el
papá no ha podido dejar pasar y lo
plantea y lo plantea con la claridad que
lo hace por el otro lado si
efectivamente su iglesia sigue tan necsa
de acuerdo a la era de putin es muy
difícil y efectivamente vuelva a existir
un nuevo diálogo aunque el papá dice que
sigue dispuesto a seguir dialogando
buscando la paz